A quick phone call to a colleague nearby.
Everyone in the neighborhood is waiting for
an electricity worker to arrive.
With the flick of a switch, they turn off
electricity in one neighborhood, and power
up somewhere else.
Gaza is getting very little electricity from
the Israeli grid.
"My colleague here was waiting for a call
from someone at the Eastern line to switch
on the electricity.
What happened is he just shut off the connection
from the Western side because this neighborhood's
turn is over."
Just a few streets away, Maisa Sultan is hurrying
to fill the washing machine.
Her neighborhood has electricity again – but
only for a precious three hours a day.
All of that in the middle of the summer.
“When the electricity comes on, I start
washing my laundry, and do anything else I
need energy for.
I have to do this all very quickly.“
Even the makeshift battery system, which supplies
a little light during a blackout, needs to
be charged.
Nothing works - refrigerators, water pumps,
elevators.
Last week, the two million inhabitants of
Gaza had to make do with as little as two
hours of power every day.
“The situation is going from bad to worse.
But if our self-proclaimed leaders in Gaza
and the West Bank would not just consider
their own interests, but finally take the
wishes of the people into account, then something
might change.“
Gaza has been blockaded by Israel and Egypt
for more than a decade.
In April, Gaza's only power plant had to be
shut down because of a lack of fuel.
Since then, Gaza has depended on energy from
Egypt and Israel.
But last week, Israel reduced its electricity
supply at the request of Palestinian president
Mahmoud Abbas.
He's no longer wants to pay the power bill
for the Gaza Strip, which is controlled by
his rival Hamas.
„The sole alternative is for Hamas to respond
to the initiative of the President by handing
over the border crossings, reverting from
its coup and by handing over all government
institutions to the government of national
consensus.”
Hamas is under further pressure, because Qatar,
one of its main sponsors, is having problems
of its own.
Since 2014, the gulf state had been funding
streets, hospitals and even fuel.
“It is clear that the main cause of this
impasse is the Israeli occupation, in cooperation
with President Abbas.
People should protest against those behind
the blockade.
We are telling our people that they have to
tolerate more of this reality.”
On Gaza’s coastline, one can smell the fallout
of the crisis long before one sees it: This
is where the sewage from millions of Gazans
is flushed into the Mediterranean Sea.
The dirty water then flows north, towards
Israel.
“We're talking about 100,000 cubic meters
of sewage water, that reaches the beach.
It's either only partially purified or not
at all.”
And while Egypt recently delivered a small
amount of fuel to the Gaza Strip, that shipment
was just a drop in the bucket in an ever-worsening
crisis.